ja genau so ist es meine damen und
herren ich begrüße sie herzlich aus dem
reichstagsgebäude der bundestag hat
gestern bis knapp 2 uhr beraten und er
hat auch nur dann aufgehört nachdem ein
hammelsprung den dfb beantragt hatte
schief gegangen ist war nicht mehr genug
abgeordnete dafür die abstimmung heute
geht es also hier weiter und das thema
heute vor allen dingen steht da die
bundeswehr im mittelpunkt es geht
nämlich zum einen um die nato nord ost
erweiterung beitritt von finnland und
schweden deutschland wird das erste land
sein was heute sowohl im bundestag wie
auch im bundesrat diesen beitritt
ratifizieren wird und dann geht es um
die folgen des gipfels in madrid der
nato nämlich um eine neue streitkräfte
struktur auch das große herausforderung
für die deutsche bundeswehr über die man
mal reden muss und das werde ich jetzt
tun mit den beiden
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher von
fdp und afg alexander müller und rüdiger
lucassen herr müller fange ich mit ihnen
kurz an
die finden und die norweger wollen
pardon wo die schweden wollen jetzt also
in die nato das sind zwei länder die
haben hervorragend armeen die sind gut
ausgebildet die sind auch stärken mäßig
recht ordentlich aufgestellt allerdings
bringen sie 1300 kilometer grenze zu
russland mit ist das jetzt für den rest
dann hatte den 30 anderen die das jetzt
ratifizieren müssen eigentlich eine
stärkung oder eine schwächung dieser
beitritt ich sehe dass eine stärkung
denn diese grenze war ja schon immer
vorhanden und die bedrohung für finnland
war ja auch schon immer da das heißt die
insbesondere die finden haben eine sehr
lange grenze und die sind darauf
vorbereitet finnland und schweden beide
haben sehr starke armeen und das wird
die nato insgesamt stärken herr lucas
putin hat sich doch scheinbar völlig
verrechnet jetzt gibt es nämlich dann
doch länder die der nato beitreten also
eine weitere ost-erweiterung das wollte
er verhindern und die nato die mal von
dem ein oder anderen schon als hirntot
bezeichnet wurde die ist jetzt wieder
richtig zusammen gerutscht man hat das
gefühl da tut sich was hat sich putin da
völlig verrechnet also ich bin 1973
soldat geworden also soldat in der zeit
des kalten krieges wir hätten uns damals
sicherlich diese unterstützung im
nordosten gewünscht jetzt kommt sie
innerhalb von wenigen wochen also ganz
klar putin muss sich da verrechnet haben
herr müller die dieser beitritt der
beiden länder ist ja nicht ganz ohne
kritik die linke wird hier heute mit
nein stimmen und zwar argumentiert sie
da gab es einen schmutzigen deal
zwischen der türkei und diesen beiden
beitrittsstaaten in der tat verlangt der
türkische präsident die auslieferung
unter anderem von 78 menschen die in
schweden zuflucht gesucht haben von der
grünen bewegung zb ehemalige pkk leute
ist das der preis wert bei der linken
darf man da nicht so genau darauf gucken
die linke ist generell nato-gegner das
ist nun mal so und deswegen werden wir
würden die auch mit anderen mitteln die
den beitritt ablehnen was man jetzt im
herrn erdogan genau zugesagt hat ist
noch unklar ob er wirklich durchgesetzt
hat dass ausgeliefert werden muss ist
noch nicht klar klar ist dass er eine
andere auffassung von terrorismus hat
als manch anderer und dass er gewisse
forderungen stellen wird
sicherheitsgarantien haben will aber ob
da jetzt wirklich menschen ausgeliefert
werden muss man mal schauen es ist ein
problem herr lucassen wie wird die ard
damit umgehen auch mit der abstimmung
heute wenn sie zustimmen wir werden
diesen beitritt zustimmen aber die rolle
der türkei im ganzen
ganzen prozess des beitritts von
finnland und schweden wird wirklich
einen schatten auf
diese politik und vor allen dingen auf
die türkei eine so und verlässlicher
partner der europa erpresst in der tat
erpresst auch mit der lieferung von f 16
kampfflugzeugen für sein votum der
gehört nicht in ruhe in die europäische
union und die europäische gemeinschaft
da gehört er auch noch nicht zu aber er
ist nato mitglied das ist ja
grundsätzlich herr müller immer schon
ein problem gewesen da auf der flanke
mit den griechen gemeinsam das wird
keine große freundschaft mehr werden man
ist doch immer wieder überrascht welche
reibereien der auftreten und die nato
hat aber genauso wie die europäische
union eigentlich keine richtige handhabe
gegen diesen türkischen sonderweg sage
ich mal ja man muss halt immer sehen die
eu ist eine bewährte partnerschaft
während die nato ein militärbündnis ist
das ist ein unterschied das heißt es
gibt keine keine werte partnerschaft mit
der türkei dass wir im bereich
menschenrechte zb uns einig wären aber
man muss auch sehen wenn man jetzt
versuchen würde die türkei in
irgendeiner form loszuwerden was ohnehin
nicht geht das funktioniert nicht aber
dann würden die sich wahrscheinlich sehr
schnell russland annähern und das wäre
für die sicherheit in europa nicht gut
und deswegen müssen wir schauen wie wir
diplomatisch das problem gelöst werden
man muss aber auch als deutschland
schauen wie man das inhaltlich hinkriegt
die noch in das neue streitkräfte modell
was in madrid beraten worden ist das
sieht einen aufwuchs der schnellen
eingreifkräfte von 40.000 auf 300.000
soldatinnen und soldaten vor das ist
eine menge und auch deutschland ist der
massiv gefordert 15.000 soldaten sollen
zur verfügung gestellt werden die sofort
innerhalb kürzester zeit an den
brennpunkt erscheinen könnten mann hatte
das in der mittelfristplanung der
bundeswehr immer schon mal angedacht für
das jahr 2028 jetzt sagt die
verteidigungsministerien wir geben uns
alle mühe bis 20 24h stoltenberg ist
sehr optimistisch und redet von 20 23
ist das überhaupt zu schaffen für die
bundeswehr also es ist absolut nicht
danach aus und hat sich die
verteidigungsministerin mit sicherheit
mal wieder sehr weit aus dem fenster
gelehnt die kräfte wie etf die 20 23
bereitstehen sollen wird die
bundesregierung das bmvg kaum schaffen
aufzustellen jetzt also bis 20 24 25 1
division sec wie valente und das sind ja
15.000 soldaten zusätzlich mit 65
luftfahrzeugen und 20 marineeinheiten da
kann jeder eine sachkundige
verteidigungspolitiker egal von welcher
fraktion ihnen erklären dass wird das
bmvg nicht schaffen zumal die bundeswehr
ja selbst noch eine lücke hat von rund
20.000 soldaten von 183.000 auf 203.000
die beabsichtigt sind und wir haben uns
fünf auslandseinsätze über 2000
soldatinnen und soldaten gebunden ist
die bundeswehr im moment überhaupt in
der lage diese personal anforderungen
alleine zu erfüllen das programm ist
ambitioniert das ist ganz klar da muss
die bundeswehr sich ganz schön strecken
aber das ist zu schaffen es ist ja nicht
so dass wir die dass wir jetzt 15.000
neue soldaten einstellen müssten um
diese division aufstellen zu können
sondern die soldatinnen und soldaten
sind vorhanden sie werden halt anders
befohlen in zukunft das heißt in zukunft
wird in brüssel von der nato aus
entschieden ob die soldatinnen und
soldaten eingesetzt werden oder nicht da
gibt es eine notice to move eine neue
projekt und es ist halt dann nicht mehr
der generalinspekteur der über die
soldaten frei verfügen kann sondern
brüssel die nato besser sein aber die
soldatinnen und soldaten sind
größtenteils vorhanden wir werden
natürlich weiter rekrutieren müssen aber
wir müssen nicht 15.000 soldaten neu
einstellen dafür ist da was dran dass
die verteidigung deutschlands jetzt
nicht mehr am hindukusch stattfindet
sondern an der ostflanke der nato würden
sie das unterschreiben
wir sind vor diese tatsache gestellt
worden der angriffskrieg putins hat
zwangsläufig die bedrohungsanalyse die
schon seit 2014 natürlich bestanden hat
noch mal verstärkt und insofern wenn
verteidigt werden muss dann in europa
und deswegen ist auch der beitritt
finnland und schweden es eine große
stärke und sie muss genutzt werden den
europäischen pfeiler der nato deutlicher
herauszustellen es geht nicht mehr um
irgend eine europäische armee und es
muss auch um mehr unabhängigkeit von den
usa gehen der europäische pfeiler der
nato wird gestärkt
diese 15.000 mann sind vorhanden haben
sie gerade gesagt werden
und ein anderes kommando gestellt ist
das auch einer der gründe warum die
verteidigungsministerin sich wirklich
äußerst zäh an stellt bei der frage
waffen an die ukraine abzugeben weil die
vielleicht gar nicht vorhanden sind wir
gerne rad inspektor hat auch gesagt wir
brauchen unsere 824 fuchs panzer gestand
ist ja da eine abstimmung der cdu/csu
abgeschmettert worden ist das wirklich
so der vater ihr parteifreund hat gesagt
das ist doch quatsch wir können denen
sofort 200 panzer liefern
das können wir nicht der
generalinspekteur hat glaube ich da die
meiste ahnung und er hat ganz klar
gesagt die 200 füchse brauchen wir da
muss man auch dazu sehen die ukraine
braucht mannschaftstransportfahrzeuge
der fuchs ist ein
mannschaftstransportfahrzeug aber der
fuchs in der bundeswehr hat verschiedene
aufgaben der ist abc spürpanzer der ist
sanitätsfahrzeug der ist funk stöhr
wagen mit ganz vielen antennen obendrauf
und dieser umbau ist sehr schwierig sie
können nicht jeden fuchs einfach in
einen mannschaftstransportwagen umbauen
und deswegen sagt der generalinspekteur
so einfach ist es nicht wir können die
füchse nicht einfach ausschneiden wir
haben bündnisverpflichtungen wir haben
ein fähigkeitsprofil das wollen wir für
die bundeswehr erhalten wir wollen
verteidigungs bereit sein und wenn wir
diese anforderungen erfüllen wollen und
das ist auch unser gemeinsamer antrag im
bundestag vom april auf den die cdu ja
rekurriert der sagt genau dass wir
müssen verteidigungsfähigkeiten dann
dürfen wir nicht einfach große mengen
material einfach ausschneiden und
abgeben ich kann mich an ein interview
von robert habeck erinnern was ihr
glaube in der ard gegeben hat wohl
gesagt hat es ja die frage wo wir uns
verteidigen ist das in der ukraine schon
die verteidigung der westlichen
wertegemeinschaft dann können wir da
auch material hingeben ich weiß dass ich
sehr kritisch damit dem einsatz in der
ukraine sind aber als ehemaliger militär
wäre es nicht notwendig wenn man der
ukraine helfen will jetzt richtig massiv
dort zu helfen auch mit material also
auf jeden fall muss man erst mal
feststellen ist die ukraine kein
nato-mitglied so einfach ist es also
nicht
dort sich auch militärisch zu engagieren
und wir stehen diesen waffenlieferungen
auch sehr ambivalent gegenüber
denn sie sind zum einen und das kann
niemand bestreiten auch eine
voraussetzung dafür dass ein krieg
eskalieren kann und jeder eskalation
gilt es zu vermeiden sondern diesem
gebiet möglichst schnell zu beenden na
ja gut aber das wird dann der diktat
friese werden den herr putin dann
erlassen wird lukas und das will
natürlich weder der bundeskanzler noch
die westliche gemeinschaft das
sehe ich noch nicht unbedingt so dass es
ein gag habt frieden werden muss es gibt
ja auch andere möglichkeiten außer
militärischen die russische föderation
so unter druck zu setzen dass sie von
form von weiteren kriegerischen
absichten ablässt und das ist zu
verhandlungen kommen kann die müssen
erst mal begonnen werden es ist
überhaupt nicht zu erkennen dass die
bundesregierung sich in jeglicher weise
bemüht verhandlungen internationale
verhandlungen in gang zu setzen ich habe
da wenn wir uns das angucken was auf die
bundeswehr dazu kommt unabhängig jetzt
von der frage wie viele waffen wir noch
an die ukraine liefern werden dann muss
man schon sagen wie können wir das in
zukunft erfüllen
183.000 soldatinnen und soldaten hat die
bundeswehr im moment die meisten sind
keine wehrpflichtigen es gibt ja den
einen oder anderen einer steht neben
ihnen der die wehrpflicht fordert wäre
das in dieser situation sinnvoll nein
die wehrpflicht würde uns überhaupt
nicht weiter helfen erstes mal so
unrealistisch unrealistisch weil wir die
kapazitäten gar nicht haben wir müssten
kaserne und bauen die wehrpflichtigen
werden ja untergebracht die schlafen ja
in der kaserne das haben wir alles gar
nicht wir haben keine ausbilder wir
haben nicht die uniformen waffen und so
weiter all das müssen wir erst mal uns
zu legen dass wir gleich wieder 100
milliarden paket was wir erstmal braucht
um überhaupt eine wehrpflicht einführen
zu können wir haben ja
1457 liegenschaften und die bundeswehr
besitzt ein gelände was
zusammengerechnet größer ist als das
saarland wir haben nicht genug platz um
neue rekruten unterzubringen das ist ein
komisches album platz haben wir schon
aber keine gebäude die grundstücke haben
wir aber bauen sieht man bei der
bundeswehr eine neue kaserne erwarten
sie 15 jahre von dem er von dem ersten
planungsschritt bis das ding gebaut ist
viel spaß da können sie in 15 jahren
wehrpflicht haben hassan c forderns wie
soll das gelingen also ich muss meinen
geschätzten kollegen müller absolut
widersprechen das ist eine antwort auf
eine wehrpflicht wie sie vor 2011 war da
muss man auch neu denken man muss nicht
gleich alle wehrpflichtigen in kasernen
stopfen das eine zeigt uns ja auch
variable modelle wie sie sie in schweden
üblich sind wichtig ist dass
wehrpflichtige kommen und ihr aufgaben
im grundbetrieb übernehmen für die wir
keine spezialist spezialisten brauchen
damit die bundeswehr spezialisten
freisetzen kann für höherwertige
aufgaben und es ist vor allen dingen
auch eine ja eine volks moralische
angelegenheit denn deutschland muss erst
mal erkennen dass es eine faire
fähigkeit benötigt wir können darüber
diskutieren dass wir eine bedrohung
haben aber wenn das deutsche volk und
alle rechtmäßig in diesem land lebenden
menschen das nicht nachvollziehen dann
ist nichts damit gewonnen der herr lucas
einen punkt gemacht denn in der tat ist
es ja in der ampelkoalition sodass der
linkere teilen ihre ampel koalition in
der tat glaube ich noch nicht so weit
ist zu sagen das wird unsere zukunft und
unsere realität sei nicht nur die 100
milliarden wir brauchen die zwei prozent
militär um unser jetziges leben
abzusichern ist wieder notwendig man
hatte ja geglaubt dass nach der block
konfrontation das leben herrlich wird
und nie wieder irgendeine deutsche waffe
irgendwo kämpfen muss aber die realität
scheint doch eine ganz andere zu werden
oder ja und bei mich als fdp-vertreter
brauchen sie da nicht katholisch machen
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag versucht
die zwei prozent rein zu verhandeln es
ist uns damals nicht gelungen unsere
partner wollten das nicht wir haben uns
auf den kompromiss geeinigt und haben
das drei prozent ziel führt apple die
also die fans verteidigung development
entwicklung und diplomacy also
auswärtige abend insgesamt rein
verhandelt aber wir hätten uns die zwei
prozent gewünscht und wir fordern die
auch seit vielen jahren also mit der fdp
haben so gar kein problem litauen ist
ein schwachpunkt
in der verteidigungsfähigkeit der nato
denn da ist das territorium zu
kaliningrad aber auch zu belarus glaube
ich 80 kilometer ist das maximal da
diese enge und da ist ja deutschland
jetzt schon aktiv mit 1000 soldaten die
verteidigungsminister hat glaube ich
noch im frühjahr gesagt wir haben
natürlich probleme bei solchen einsätzen
weil teilweise unsere funkgeräte nicht
kompatibel sind mit denen der anderen
nato staaten jetzt wollen wir innerhalb
kürzester zeit dort weitere 600 soldaten
hinschicken wir müssen insgesamt 15.000
bereitstellen für den gesamt aufwuchs
der schnellen eingreifkräfte sind wir
überhaupt technisch in der lage das bis
zum nächsten jahr so stoltenberg sagt
oder vielleicht bis zum übernächsten
jahr was die verteilungs ministerin sagt
zu leisten also die kompatibilität von
gerätschaften in streitkräften das ist
immer ein problem gewesen und mit diesem
schnellen nato beitritt von vielen
ländern seit 99 2004 und jetzt schweden
und finnland wird dieses problem nicht
geringer werden aber das muss die
operation von streitkräften nicht
mindern es kommt immer darauf an auf
welcher ebene die operation durchgeführt
wird und es muss nicht immer die
unterste ebene vollkommen kompatibel
miteinander sein also das halte ich
durchaus für möglich aber es ist vor
allen dingen eine geostrategische
komponente mit dem beitritt von finnland
jetzt die baltischen staaten auch zu
sichern heisst auch den ostseeraum zu
beherrschen das ist natürlich ein
vorteil für die nato in der tat ich habe
es ganz am anfang gesagt eigentlich die
beiden länder gut aufgestellt jetzt
kommt nur noch die spezialität dazu
dauerhaft kann man dort keine nato
soldaten stationieren wegen der
deutschland russland aktuell wegen der
nach dem russland akte wie wird das in
zukunft aussehen werden dort nato
truppen stationiert oder sind beide
länder starke noch zunächst alleine zu
agieren ich denke überwiegend werden die
soldatinnen und soldaten hier sein wir
werden das material wahrscheinlich
größtenteils bereits dort im baltikum
stationieren damit weil die notice to
move einfach reduziert wird wir müssen
uns schneller bewegen können wir müssen
kaltstart fähig sein in der zukunft aber
die große masse der soldatinnen soldaten
wird hier sein aber weil sie die nato
russland kontakte ansprechen dieses
rotationsprinzip was da drin steht also
keine feste stationierung ich denke
daran wird gerüttelt weil die grundlagen
der nato russland aktie ja auch weg sind
die nato russland akte geht von einem
friedlichen verhalten aller aus dass hat
russland definitiv gebrochen und da
diskutiert man im moment darüber wie man
mit dieser akte insgesamt generell
umgehen will hätte herr lucas und vielen
dank drin geht es jetzt los von der
damen und herren beitritt beitritt von
schweden und finnland in die nato der
deutsche bundestag und heute nachmittag
der bundesrat wird das ratifizieren
damit wird deutschland der erste von 30
nato-staaten seien allerdings ist die
frage ob es dann wirklich zum beitritt
kommt dass hinter letztlich an der
türkei warten wir es mal ab und ich
geben